beautiful what's going on yeah filthy
sexy bastard look at you with your cute
ass so better get your cell phone outta
here now if you guys have noticed with
these videos it's that really
everything's kind of freeze down I guess
you could say with these videos they're
just like thoughts and like a visual
video podcast that aren't you know short
what am I saying
it's just me blabbing and I know you
guys want to hear a lot of opinions so
these are just opinions none of these
are facts sometimes when people listen
to these videos they're like oh my god I
don't agree with you guess what it's
okay if you don't [ __ ] agree I'm give
up but it's just me having thoughts
you're allowed to have your thoughts I'm
allowed to have mine and that's
completely okay let's just be civil with
our discourse shall we you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was talking to somebody not too long
ago and when we had lunch
this person kind of talked to me about
how they're constantly stressed out and
I asked this person why they're always
stressed out and what it kind of boiled
down to was that this specific person
who was a friend of mine seems to care a
lot about what other people think about
what's going on in their lives now I
know that she is not the only person
that's going through this and I feel
like a lot of people go through this as
well and what I boil this down to is
something called always giving a [ __ ]
syndrome now there's a few ways to tell
if you have always giving a [ __ ]
syndrome number one if somebody doesn't
agree with you you get upset for the
whole [ __ ] day that is a clear sign
that you give way too many [ __ ] and I'm
only mentioning this if this person who
said something to you that's disagreeing
with you about something that you care
about it's somebody that you barely
[ __ ] know if it's somebody you barely
[ __ ] know I mean really why do you
care so much about what a random [ __ ]
stranger thinks about I really don't
understand that if you want to care
about somebody's opinion about you it
should probably be the people who know
you the best who care about you the most
and when they give you advice of some
sort it's usually in your best interest
when strangers who give no [ __ ] care
about how your life goes
you should not write a ticket out of
this is my [ __ ] I'm gonna give it to you
because I'm beautiful no who cares
life is too short to care about what
somebody else thinks that does not have
a significant effect on your life now
this in general doesn't mean that when
somebody says something disrespectful to
you or disagrees on something once again
that you care about that it doesn't it's
not supposed to bother you a little bit
the big difference is is how it bothers
you and how long it bothers you for I
just found out recently that somebody
that I met like one time I think a
couple of months ago has been talking a
lot of [ __ ] about me now for me it's I
understand that when they when this
person I met okay so this is what I
basically happened so basically the
reason why this guy doesn't like me is
because when I met him in like the first
like hour or so I couldn't help but make
fun of the dude no I know this sounds
like an [ __ ] thing and it probably
was in my case but the reason why I did
is because he's that type of dude that
even if you don't [ __ ] know him that
well like I just met the guy the guy
tries to have like this like gross
session rapport with you you know I'm
saying like if you know your friend for
a long time you could say whatever the
[ __ ] you want to him you could come up
to them you can make fun of his weight
his hair whatever but because you guys
are good friends you guys have that it's
like with me and Bart Bart comes up and
roast me 24 [ __ ] 7 that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that's okay because that's
what our friendship is based on that's
like eight to nine years of friendship
but if I don't know you when you try to
come at me with that heat you will
[ __ ] get it so as we're eating and me
and my friend are talking about our past
and we're making it a couple of jokes at
each other he comes in with this really
like awkward joke about me and I was
like who the [ __ ] are you hey you know
the first one I kind of let go and they
start doing it again and again and so
during the meal and it was in front of a
few other people too I looked at him I
said so when people didn't laugh at the
first three jokes what made you think
the fourth one was gonna be funny and he
kind of stopped and he was stuttering a
little bit he goes oh I didn't mean to
offend you and I was like no no it's not
that you're being offensive you're being
socially [ __ ] awkward you keep on
trying to make jokes trying to make
everybody laugh but you're making
everybody feel weird and now that I
spoke up about it now you're trying to
make it seem like I made things weird
so what you can do is eat your hamburger
shut the [ __ ] up and just chill the [ __ ]
out I don't know
like that so clearly I came at the Duke
kind of aggressive but you know I gave
the guy a couple warnings and he just
kept doing it over and over so what was
I supposed to do I'm not somebody that
really tends to keep quiet
so anyways dinner is going on he tries
to make another joke and I'm just like
Oh awkward guys talking again - the guy
was getting irritated so he stopped
making those jokes for the rest of the
dinner so anyways I met up with my
friend again he was like yo I'm sorry
about that last situation you know that
guy [ __ ] hates you he's still talking
about you till this day and the reason
why I bring that up is because it's so
[ __ ] awkward like somebody like him
doesn't understand who the [ __ ] am I who
am I to you
if anything else I didn't think about
you for that whole whatever month ago I
don't know a few weeks that that person
is somebody who literally gives too much
[ __ ] and you don't want to be that
person you know what I'm saying
he gave too much [ __ ] at their dinner
table that he wanted to entertain
everybody he wanted to be the center of
attention he wanted people to laugh and
think that he was an awesome person at
the expense of somebody else and then on
top of that me a person that he met one
time for the past like couple three I
don't know two three weeks or a month or
whatever he's still talking about man
he's still upset me somebody he doesn't
really know do not be that person
guy if you ever watch this [ __ ] video
and you want to talk to me in person you
could you already know you have my
contact through our friend go ahead but
at the end of the day what I'm saying is
you give way too many [ __ ] and don't be
like this dude it's too stressful to
care so much about what somebody else
thinks about you that doesn't really
give a [ __ ] about you do you understand
what I'm saying I see it all the time I
see it on Instagram I see it on Twitter
and Twitter is like the best example of
people who give way too many [ __ ] it's
almost as if Twitter is the space for
everybody to complain just to get a
retweet so people could be on their side
you ever see those [ __ ] weird tweets
they'll tweet one little like me mobile
whatever tweet and the next thing you
see right under on my Instagram follow
this oh how the people are following me
anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ] like even for me you guys
know I get upset about a lot of things
but my upset moment is simply to turn it
into something funny and that's just
kind of how I go about my life because
life is too short
to really genuinely be upset at
everything my best advice to people is
stop caring
about everything and only care about
things that'll help you progress as a
human being you have personal
relationships you can work on you have
personal goals that you can work on and
when you give a [ __ ] about what somebody
else says about you you give that person
power whoa think about that for a
[ __ ] second some people are out there
giving away [ __ ] like their Oprah and
[ __ ] you know I'm saying you get a [ __ ]
you get a [ __ ] you get a [ __ ] yeah
nobody in this world is worth that time
if they are not important to you get
that in your [ __ ] head
I'll even give you another example how
many times I don't know how old
everybody is out there but if you are
like above the age of like 23 or some
[ __ ] how many times do people ask or do
you get a boyfriend when are you gonna
get a girlfriend why the [ __ ] you care
when I get a boyfriend or [ __ ]
girlfriend that's on my timeline who I
get with who I stay with it's going to
affect me and not you don't worry about
me [ __ ]
I'll go [ __ ] up whatever be whatever I
want you you caring about what somebody
else thinks about your dating timeline
and having that stress you out is so
weird like I don't understand it on both
ends why do you stress out about when I
get with somebody and why the [ __ ] am I
stressed that you care about when I get
with somebody it's just the [ __ ] into
the whining web of stress for no reason
and I hate that [ __ ] so my best advice
to people is do yourself a favor and
stop giving a [ __ ]